l'autre jour j'ai tombé sur un
photographe il avait 20 ans il m'a dit
on mais lisa moi je suis là parce que tu
m'as trop donné envie enfin c'était
hyper touchant quand je me suis je me
suis mise là dedans je me suis dit vas-y
let's go va tenter mais je pensais pas
que devenir un truc aussi
un aussi gros quoi
des caves et des concerts en profitait
pour aller disputer c'est comme ça que
j'ai rencontré en 9 9,5 c'est là que
j'ai rencontré nekfeu orelsan est de
trois mois j'ai shooté avec soprano je
suis arrivé au paris saint-germain en
2013 c'était la même année aux marques
nutella sinistre voilà la même longévité
au club pouvoir shooter on est marin
messi et la vie au début je ne raconte
je ne savais pas trop comment se poser
plus bas à lui ils sont fichés je
pouvais aller sur scène avec 8 miles et
qui les inspire déjà
[Musique]
alors ici on est au label rinne snvi
bienvenue chez avec sarah magra fils et
voilà on va bosser
3 c'est un projet que j'ai depuis très
longtemps parce qu'en fait j'ai récolté
plein d'image depuis 8 9 ans et du coup
je voulais vraiment faire un bouquin
pourquoi le foot et le rap c'est parce
que déjà c'est naturellement c'est ce
que shoot depuis le début de ma carrière
de photographe et c'est vraiment deux
milieux que je trouve vraiment
identiques plus se ressemblent
énormément tue pas les footballeurs il
écoute tout le temps du rap
et les rappeurs pareil si c'était pas
fait les croisés et comme ils disent
j'aurais tout footballeur le livre
s'appelle numéro 10 c'est ça fait
référence à la première exposition que
j'ai fait en 2015
j'avais déjà fait une expo je mélangeais
les photos de foot et les photos de rap
ça le fait référence à la chanson de
booba numéro 10 déjà le numéro 10 sur un
terrain de foot en général c'est un peu
la vedette du club et surtout les
rappeurs il utilise beaucoup du coup ça
pour dire que eux mêmes sont des numéros
10 août dans leur équipe il ya que des
numéros 10 pour dire que ce sont les
meilleurs et tout ça j'ai trouvé ça cool
en fait d'utiliser ce terme fait en gros
le livre il souffre dans les deux sens
une partie sur le foot
et après le livre tu pourras le
retourner comme ça et l'autre partie
sera sur le rap alors du coup là c'est
les pages qu'on a validée et on va voir
les pages imprimé chez l'imprimeur et
comparées pour que ce soit la même
promis
on s'occupe des couleurs d'égaliser mais
rentrer c'est pour trouver notre couleur
parfaite
[Musique]
du coup là on va à paris on a un shoot
avec belleton qui est un artiste du neuf
de vie donc le label de booba et ce soir
on est au parc des princes pour le match
psg nantes du coup là je suis sur le
instagram de l'artiste qu'on va shooter
pour m'inspirer un peu de son image de
son univers de
le genre d'image qu'il aime poster de
lui ce qui est bien c'est que c'est la
cité d'oullins artistes donc lui va
connaître un peu je pense des endroits
style et il va se sentir à l'aise donc
c'est ce qui compte
je pense qu'on va le jouer au feeling
c'est ce que je préfère faire
j'aime bien préparé des fois mes shoots
et tout mais je t'avoue que c'est
toujours du freestyle c'est toujours là
qui fait les meilleures images c'est
contre le temps il a un peu nuageux
comme ça finalement c'est presque le
meilleur temps pour les photos parce
qu'il ya trop de soleil et une paire de
manche les autres je suis en train de
regarder quels plans elle mieux donc je
suis petit repérage d'art
après j'ai l'impression que tu dis que
tout est beau temps actuel dit
honnêtement je te croyais à
bages essaie de le mettre un petit peu
en confiance mais sa as il a l'air
d'être assez détendu donc c'est cool
depuis toujours je shoote des rappeurs
qui n'ont pas forcément l'habitude de
passer par des mannequins de base c'est
des artistes
c'est plus je travaille avec des gens et
plus je me suis rendu compte de
l'importance de l'image et que c'est
aussi important de travailler ce rapport
de confiance pour travailler sur du long
terme en
[Musique]
mai arrivée au parc des princes comme
vous voyez on est devant et on va
rentrer par l'entrée des photographes il
va
donc moi j'arrive je mets ma musique je
me mets dans mon monde et je commençais
à shooter voilà je prie pour que quand
les mecs qui marquent ils viennent
célébrer mon côté donc ça c'est toujours
un peu le petit suspense et pis c'est ça
des fois c'est vraiment le casse tête tu
dis bonjour ma gauche je me mets à
droite donc c'est vrai que j'arrivais
là-bas bon je voyais pas de femme mais
je me suis jamais dit oh purée c'est
trop bizarre et a pas de femme j'étais
juste là bas et voila quoi j'ai pas non
je n'ai pas trop remarqué après oui
c'est sûr que avec du recul je me dis
assez fou quoi mais au moins là ça a
évolué c'est clair que maintenant elle a
beaucoup plus donc tant mieux on a
l'impression que ces décès des personnes
inaccessibles les clubs c'est
inaccessible alors que alors que non
quand tu tentes si ton travail les biens
tas d exemple à montrer sur ton travail
on va te laisser sa chance donc oui
c'est je pense que j'ai un peu ouvert la
voie sans prétention sélectionner les
photos sympas c'était laquelle qu'on
avait
j'essaie de faire rapidement parce que
probablement que les joueurs ils ont
envie d'en poster une ou deux donc le
but c'est ça c'est d'aller assez vite
pour leur envoyer
parce que je postais assez rapidement
après le match autant des fois tu
arrives et à la photo iconique ça fait
vraiment partie du jeu quoi et ça qui
est excitant ce que j'essaie de faire
dégager dans mes photos c'est l'émotion
vu que dans le foot que ce soit une
célébration même quand les mecs défaut
il se blesse écrit j'aime bien même
quand des fois ils se disputent je
trouve ça intense donc j'aime bien
après les concerts ça dépend les
artistes mais oui tu c'est toujours ça
s'est toujours montré le spectacle
montre et l'émotion et oui comme je
disais c'est ça pour moi qui fais une
belle photo
[Musique]